Queen in F6
- Papa?
- Yes?
There is something I still cannot fully understand
- What is that?
- Why do the pieces sacrifice themselves for each other?
It’s a tactic...
...within a larger strategy
Checkmate
Ultimately protecting...
...what is most precious to them
Papa?
What’s wrong?
I’m fine, boy. It’s just… It’s just my eyes
I must go out to buy a new pair of glasses
Now?
I won’t be long. We’ll pick up where we left off
- Can I come with you?
- No. I must go myself
I’ve told you it’s not safe
Papa?
Don’t touch me
No!
Nice Eyes and Ears, old man
Why not give them to someone young enough to enjoy them?
Militia! Militia!
Alright, old boy
What can I do for you?
I need a used Immersion System
Late model with audio-visual
No olfactory
You’re not still living with that… thing, are you?
What’s built from military scavenge
will always be military
It’s a weapon at heart
This...
This came off a guy that was zipped by the militia last week
Almost perfect condition
The ID’s not wiped. You'll have to do that yourself
Look, I didn’t mean anything by…
You know…
Militia!
Oh God. Not again!
Wait!
- Sorry, old boy! Every man for himself!
- Let me in!
This your shack?
Where did you find that Immersyst?
Stop!
Papa?
- Papa?
- Boy! Go home!
What’s this?
Your doll?
Watch out! It’s unspecked hardware!
Looks like military grade! Do not engage!
Well, well, well. What do we have here?
Let my papa go!
Oh…
“Let my papa go”!
Hey!
Toaster oven!
Do you think you’re human?
- What did you say to me?
- Don’t touch me!
Please stop!
Papa?
Are you my papa?
Run, boy, run!
No!
Stop!
Conflict ended. Defense mode de-activated
Papa
You may come out
I’m sorry...
I’m so sorry
I will make things the way they were before
I will erase it all away
I love you papa
Papa
Son?
Papa? Have you been crying?